it's michelle from lab muffin beauty
science here chemistry phd and skincare
nerd
and person who hates washing their face
over the sink so today i thought i'd
show you how i remove my makeup and wash
my face
without using a sink while busting some
cleanser mitts
i already busted a whole bunch of myths
that people sent in but i couldn't
finish busting them all
i used to use this method a lot when i
was camping and on the plane and i've
been using this method in australia
because it's currently
winter here and i hate washing my face
at night and having the water drip down
my wrists and
into my sleeves and then i have to go to
sleep wearing wet sleeves
i'm going to start by removing my eye
makeup with a two-phase eye makeup
remover
i don't think i've ever talked about
this one before but it's the garnier
clean sensitive two-in-one gentle makeup
remover these two face removers have two
layers the blue layer is an oily layer
this one is based on cyclopentasiloxane
which is a silicone that's very light
and evaporates easily the bottom layer
is water-based and it's got lots of
humectants in it to hydrate i use it
with a reusable cotton velour pad this
one is from the brand bamboo
so with these you just shake it up first
and then you pour it onto the pad
i really like these two face makeup
removers because they take off
waterproof eye makeup
really gently and quickly without too
much tugging or irritation
micellar water works for this too but i
find that these ones are just a bit
quicker when i'm traveling i use
micellar water because it just means i
have one less thing to carry
i found that some of these two in one
makeup removers do leave a little bit of
an oily residue
it really depends on which one you're
using and where you're using it as well
this one doesn't leave too much of a
residue but it is still there i don't
mind that oily feeling near my eyes but
i really don't like it on other parts of
my face so if you don't like that oily
film or you're trying to put makeup on
top right away
then i would recommend a micellar water
instead okay let's get into the mix
again unfortunately a lot of these
answers aren't just a simple yes or no
that is actually really how a lot of
these myths came about there is some
grain of truth in there
first myth you need to use an oil-based
cleanser to remove makeup or sunscreen
because oil dissolves oil
you don't it really depends on how
strong your cleanser is how resistant
your sunscreen and makeup are
and really what you prefer to use in
your routine all cleanses weren't really
popular in skincare until pretty
recently and people got on fine without
it and that's even with things like
grease paint that you use for stage
makeup
if you think about washing greasy dishes
you don't need a cleansing oil to wash
those you just use dishwashing liquid
the reason is dishwashing liquid and
regular cleansers have
ingredients in them called surfactants
so factors look like this they have a
water loving head
and an oily tail that likes oil in the
one package
so that means the factors can help oil
droplets go into water and then they can
be washed off so that oil dissolves oil
thing still works because
that oily surfactant tail can basically
behave like an oil analysis skin
perspective on instagram she's a great
person to follow
she did this cool demonstration with a
uv camera after putting on a water
resistant sunscreen she washed one side
of her face with a regular gel cleanser
and the other side with a cleansing oil
followed by a gel cleanser
and you can see both sides ended up
around the same but a lot of people
including me still
really like using a cleansing oil or
balm first i like using very gentle
foaming cleansers and i like the feeling
of rubbing a balm
on my face it's really just a preference
so cleansing balm followed by a foaming
cleanser works best for me
now i'm moving on to a cleansing bun
this is then i met you living cleansing
bum this is one of my all-time favorite
products i actually got caroline hirons
onto it as well the next myth
is you need to use a water-based
cleanser after a cleansing oil to remove
the oil
this really depends on the cleansing oil
some of these leave more of a film
and others don't you can usually let the
oily residue stay on your face but some
people don't like the feel of that
that's the main reason i personally use
a water-based cleanser afterwards
sometimes i won't if i want to leave
that oil on my skin if my skin's feeling
really dry
i find that my skin tends to quite like
the oil but if your skin is breaking out
for example you might want to wash off
that oil and of course it really depends
on your skin and the particular oils in
your cleansing oil
when i normally cleanse at this stage i
would step into the shower and wash this
off but i'm not about to strip
and do that for you that is premium
content for a different website
so instead i'm going to be using a wet
cotton cloth to wipe this off this cloth
is from alpha h it comes in a set of
seven
it's really handy when i'm traveling
i'll sometimes use the makeup wipe for
this stage
so the next question is are makeup wipes
really bad
i guess it's a no makeup wipes aren't
that good for the environment and if
it's your only cleansing step then
it's probably not that good a lot of
makeup wipes just have water and a bit
of solvent in them they don't have
surfactants and so they're not going to
be as effective at removing
water resistant sunscreen and makeup as
something with surfactants
there are some wipes that use similar
ingredients to micellar water and those
will work a lot better
and apart from not removing sunscreen
and makeup properly the fact that they
don't work very well means that people
tend to
use them too much they use them too
harshly they put too much pressure on
they tug a lot at their skin
and that leads to irritation and if
you're using makeup wise every day
and that wipe is quite rough that can
also act as a physical exfoliation step
if your skin barrier isn't quite up to
daily physical exfoliation then that can
also irritate your skin there is also
the waist issue makeup wipes are often
made using a bit of plastic
so if you're using one a day it feels
kind of unnecessary
i only really use them in rare
situations where i don't have water and
a cloth handy
so makeup wipes aren't like liquid evil
but they're probably not the best option
for your daily cleanse
now on to my next step which is wiping
down with micellar water
i'm using biodermis sensor by h2o
micellar water this is my favorite i
talked about it a whole bunch
i'm using it with a terry cloth reusable
makeup pad this one is also from bamboo
so this is really just to get rid of
that extra oil from the cleansing balm
this particular cleansing balm leaves a
bit of residue now do you need to rinse
off micellar water i'm really sorry but
the answer is
it depends it mostly depends on the
micellar water you're using
because there are lots of different
micellar waters on the market they use
lots of different ingredients and they
have different formulas
if you're not sure about your micellar
water then it's probably best to rinse
it off but this particular one was
actually specifically developed for
people with sensitive skin
living in areas where the tap water can
be quite irritating so it was
specifically developed to avoid rinsing
and it was tested on thousands of people
with sensitive skin we often think of
surfactants as
irritating ingredients that need to be
rinsed off but the class of surfactants
is
really broad almost every skin care
product you use
has surfactants in it including all your
leave-on serums and moisturizers
one of the big reasons for this
confusion is that in regular chemistry
surfactants refer to
anything with a water-loving head and an
oil-loving tail but in cosmetic
chemistry a lot of the time people use
the word surfactant just to mean
the surfactants in traditional cleanses
i think the european commission
classifies them in quite a nice way they
divide them into different subclasses
one of them is cleansing but we also
have
dispersing emulsifying foam boosting
hydrotrope and solubilizing
so there are lots of different functions
that different surfactants can have
cleansing surfactants are the ones that
you find in cleanses while emulsifying
surfactants are the ones that are
used in traditional creams and
moisturizers and a lot of serums
and they keep the oily and watery parts
of those products together so they don't
separate
if you pick up any moisturizer chances
are it'll have saturated alcohol in it
that's a fatty alcohol
if we look it up in the european
commission database it's classified as
three types of surfactant
in any moisturizer there's going to be
some sort of emulsifying surfactant
it wouldn't be a moisturizer without
that ingredient so clearly some
surfactants can be left on your skin
without problems others can't
and of course it also depends on the
concentration and the formula the
surfactant that bioderma used in this
product
is peg six caprylic capri glycerides
this is classified as an emulsifying
surfactant
it isn't used as a cleansing surfactant
in regular cleanses
when it's included in a normal cleanser
it's actually used as a super fatting
agent these are ingredients that are
added to cleanses to make them more
gentle they act like oils or emollients
they hydrate and moisturize your skin
another micellar water i really like is
this one by bioessence
my friend larry year gave it to me when
i was in singapore last he is a makeup
artist
it actually uses that same surfactant
that's in the bioderma products
peg six caprylic capric glycerides it
also uses another one called peg 7
glycerol cocoa 8. unilever have also
presented research showing that their
micellar water is as gentle as regular
water
i'm assuming it's the simple one that
one also uses that same surfactant
i think there are definitely micellar
waters out there that use less gentle
surfactants and those should probably be
rinsed off
if your skin is having trouble with any
micellar water then just rinse it off
remember it could be something else in
the formula that's causing the
irritation maybe a fragrance or a
preservative or even just the ph of the
micellar water and it could also
just be the cotton pads that you're
using with your micellar water i found
that with rougher disposable makeup
pairs
my skin got really irritated with
micellar waters and that was just from
that extra physical exfoliation sort of
like if you use the makeup wipe every
day
these reusable cotton pads are a lot
softer than the disposable pads i was
using before and i haven't had a problem
with these and you can see from the pad
that i did actually have some makeup
left on my skin
after the cleansing balm it's not just
removing the oil do you need to cleanse
in the morning do you need to double
cleanse in the morning
well you do put products on your skin at
night if you're a skincare person
and on top of that overnight your skin
produces sebum and sweat
and dust probably falls on it as well so
there is definitely stuff on your face
that could be cleansed off but
in general your face is probably pretty
clean your products also get wiped off
onto your pillowcase
and in general it's really hard for any
products to form
a solid film on your skin that won't be
disrupted for a long time
there are actually studies where people
were trying to make barrier creams that
would prevent stuff from getting into
your skin
and even when they were trying it didn't
work very well
so it isn't like you've got a layer on
your face that other skincare products
can't get through by default most
studies on cleanses have been done on
people who have acne and the protocol
is always using the cleanser twice a day
i don't think there's actually any study
that's tested once versus twice a day
with cleanses
i personally found that not washing my
face with a proper cleanser in the
morning and just splashing water on my
face and wiping it off was
actually really beneficial i have very
dehydration prone skin that gets dried
out very easily with things like
cleanses
and i always get that tight
uncomfortable feeling on my face and i
also have oily skin and i found that
once i stopped using a proper cleanse in
the morning my face was a lot more
manageable i was actually producing less
oil
my skin was more hydrated but when i was
wearing masks a lot i found that my skin
broke out a lot more
and a quick wipe with a micellar water
in the morning was actually quite
helpful for that so i think this is a
very individual thing
it really depends on your skin and the
products you're using but it isn't a
hard and fast rule that you have to
cleanse a certain number of times a day
i'm sure we all know someone who never
washes their face properly and their
skin is really happy and never breaks
out
so all of this was really just an excuse
to multitask and clean my face while
working and so
i am ready for bed now let me know if
you try out this method like subscribe
click the notification bell check out my
blog and follow me on instagram i'll see
you next time good night